welcome to google cloud next on air
in this session i'll cover what's new
with cloud sql
my name is brett hesterberg and i'm a
product manager on cloud sql
even though we can't meet in person day
i'm hopeful that we can learn a little
bit about each other
using your question pane or your comment
pane on your screen
if you feel comfortable please comment
in your
job title are you a database
administrator a reluctant database
administrator
maybe a devops engineer or a developer
or something else
also please chat in your preferred or
the
the relational database that you work on
most often maybe it's my sql
sql server uh postgres oracle
sybay stevie2 or something else we'd
love to know what you're working on
day to day also as part of google cloud
next
expert sessions i'm available to meet
one on one and talk more about cloud sql
i encourage you to reach out
today we're going to talk about four
major areas one is how we can find more
flexibility in your database
environment how we can protect against
the unexpected
gain automatic transparency and trust
and security controls and lastly we'll
round out with ways to easily stay up to
date
without the risk before we jump into
these topics
let's start with a quick look at cloud
sql cloud sql is a managed database
service
that offers mysql sql server
and postgresql this means that if you
have an application
that uses mysql sql server or postgresql
it will work with cloud c people cloud
sql focuses on managing
mundane administration aspects of these
databases and i'll talk about that a
little bit more
beyond just application compatibility it
means that
cloud sql is compatible with your
favorite
database administration tools so if
you're a sql server user for example i
encourage you to take a look at the
links on this slide here we're talking
about how sql server users can use
their favorite administration tool cloud
sql incorporating
the cloud sql proxy which makes cloud
sql instances in the cloud
look local to any machine that you're
working on
follow up on those links if you're
interested in learning more
when i think about running a database
this tends to be the technology stack or
the diagram of a stack that i think of
at the left most column we see things
related to running a data center or a
server environment in general
this means server maintenance racking
and stacking
power hvac and networking things that go
into a data center or any server
environment
of course this is taking care of for you
in the cloud
where with cloud sql when we offer an
instance and you configure the number of
ecpu cores
or ram we make sure that you get a
consistent experience that number of
cores and ram
even as our underlying hardware changes
moving one column to the right
we look at the operating system both
installation and patching are keeping
the operating system
up to date one more column to the right
is finally the database
here we're installing the database we're
keeping it up to date with its own set
of patches
and we're starting to protect data with
schedule backups
and then right most in the diagram are
things like
high availability which usually includes
some health checking and maybe automatic
failover as well as scalability where
we're using often replication
to scale out reads to replicates we want
to wrap
this whole technology stack in
monitoring so that if there is a problem
we're able to quickly find the root
cause
cloud sql's job is to take this stack or
this diagram that you see
what it really takes to run a database
and wrap all of that
in an api cli ui so that for your
application teams in your environment or
your developers
they can easily start up and create a
dev or test database which might be very
simple
but just as easily create a production
grade database
which means it includes high
availability which
relies on synchronous replication and
automatic failover
includes a backup plan for data
protection
and even cross-region replication for
disaster recovery
again all of these wrapped in an api cli
or ui
that means in just a few minutes you can
get this set up
tim sums this up well and tim kelton is
a customer at descartes labs
he says cloud sql gives his team a bit
more time to work on the products
that provide value to his customers his
team has decided
they're going to spend less time on
certain aspects of database
administration
turn those over to cloud sql so they can
focus their time elsewhere
on products that are more valuable to
their customers i think tim
sums that up well and one thing to note
here is that the diagram i showed and
was also backing tim's quote
is a dedicated sre team site reliability
engineering team for cloud sql
that is on call 24x7 these are the folks
who write the automation
to make sure our service is healthy and
runs well and when automation fails
they're also the folks who can put hands
on keyboard
to get a database back up and running
now that we've taken a look at cloud sql
we'll start to introduce
what's new what have we been up to in
the past few months and i think what
you'll find
is we have great momentum in terms of
enterprise features we're building on an
enterprise feature set with a number of
these new features that we'll cover
today
first let's find some flexibility in
your database environment
we'll start with bigquery to cloud sql
federation
this enhancement gives analysts a way to
to quickly reduce
time to value for business insight
perhaps they want to explore some data
without setting up a pipeline first
or perhaps they have a quick question
they need to answer and that data might
be spread across multiple cloud sql
instances and even other data sources
with bigquery to cloud sql federation
the analyst can query one or more cloud
sql instances
and join that data with data that
already resides in the in bigquery
or perhaps resides in one of the other
external data sources
supported by bigquery what you see in
the slide is a depiction of a very
simple query analyst is running
in bigquery where they're using the
external query function
which is what we use to ask cloud sql to
go run a query
here the the query says cloud sql has
been input by the analyst
which means we're pushing down the query
or asking cloud sql to run the advocates
for example
so we're not sending back blindly a
large table of data
the data sent back from cloud sql is in
table format
and can then be joined with other cloud
sql data other vq data or data from
another external source
supported by bigquery all of this can be
done without setting up a pipeline
and once an analyst is sure that the
insights being provided are useful
from there the team can decide to build
pipelines or a regular reporting
schedule
next we'll look at committed use
discounts and we don't often think of
pricing and flexibility in the same
sentence
hopefully what you'll find is that what
we've done with with committed use
discounts is indeed flexible
a committed use discount is ideal for
a workload with predictable resource
needs this is a way of saying
that they're great for environments
where you're running a number of cloud
sql instances
24x7 you know that each month you're
going to spend a certain amount on cloud
sql
when you commit to a one year or a three
year term with a committed use discount
or a cud as they'll call them
you can you receive either a 25 or a 52
discount one year and three year the
flexibility comes in with committed use
discounts in that
these are easily and fully transferable
between the database engines supported
by cloud sql
mysql postgresql as well as sql server
the committed use discounts or cuds
discount against the vcpus or cpu course
and ram associated with each of your
cloud sql instances
and here if your database estate changes
let's say from sql server to postgres
over time
it's no problem your cuds will continue
to apply
and you don't even need to reach out to
us not only are these
fully transferable but you don't need to
take any specific action
you purchase a committed use discount in
a uh
currency denomination for example
dollars and we
charge your instance rates against that
commitment each month
these are also fully fully transferable
between machine
sizes so you don't need to forecast
which machine size or how many cpus per
machine you'll be needing in the future
you simply use cpus as you see fit
they'll count against your committed use
discount
in this way your database and state can
change quite dramatically
over say a three year period of time
without any problems applying to
committed use discounts
we hope this will make your planning for
committed use discounts much easier with
a lot less forecasting
and that you find the whole the whole
process to be indeed flexible
looking now at how to protect the
against the unexpected we'll start with
disaster recovery in google cloud terms
we often categorize disasters as
a region outage a region in google cloud
is comprised
of three or more zones where a zone is a
separate failure domain
this means that if we have a problem in
zone a it
usually doesn't affect zone b or zone c
so a guard in itself against a regional
outage but if
a regional average were to occur where
two or more of the zones in a region are
down we have introduced
a cross-region replica enhancement or
cross-region replication enhancement
that allows you to guard against this
sort of outage a full region outage
in with a cross-region replica you're
able to ensure that you have a near
real-time copy of your data
in any region around the world other
than in your primary region
we're using google's global network as
well as google google cloud's vpcs which
are global in nature
spanning all regions in the world to
ensure that this experience is easy to
set up
and it can be made very secure and
private via our vpc option
so what you see in this slide is in the
screenshot that i'm selecting a region
something other than where i have my
primary instances of my primary instance
is in for example
us central one here i'm selecting u.s
west one as my region for the replica
and that's really about all i have to do
this will now take advantage of my
private vpc network so i know i'm
securely transferring data or copying
data rather
in near real time to my replica and the
replica is now available
in another region than my primary
instance this means in the event that i
have a
outage in my primary region u.s central
one i know i have a near real-time data
set that can be made available very
quickly
in another region in case of that
disaster of note here
is that this replica is also a standard
replica meaning
if you have users in another region who
need low latency reads to a replica
or you want to run reporting for example
on the replica you can certainly do so
knowing that the replica is still
available for disaster recovery purposes
we talked a lot about disasters and
widespread outages you all have done a
lot of disaster planning
as part of your careers in i.t
what we tend to realize though is often
the more common event is a user error
we are sort of the disaster if you will
i might drop a table
or change row data by mistake and i want
an undo button to get back in time
before i change that data so i get back
to where i was
we've long had point in time recovery
for
our mysql product in cloud sql we're now
proud to introduce it for
postgresql as well with postgresql
we store transaction logs or walls for
the past seven days
which allow you as a user to select a
millisecond
at any point in the last seven days so
if i made a mistake on a friday
afternoon for example
i don't realize it until monday morning
it's easy for me to get back to the
millisecond or the second before i made
that mistake on friday
and recover that data gives me an undo
button as i mentioned
and helps to protect against the more
common issue which is
user error
these features add to cloud sql's
enterprise ready list for data
protection and disaster recovery i think
it's worth
summarizing how to build a production
production instance with cloud sql
you start by enabling automatic daily
backups and i'd encourage you to
consider taking more frequent
on-demand backups especially when you're
making a major change to your database
for example you might be making a schema
change it's a great time to take an
on-demand backup just before you make
that change
in case anything goes wrong i'd
encourage you also to enable point in
time recovery
so that you have very granular restore
options for the last seven days as the
example was the poster sql
you can get back now to any millisecond
in time in case of a user error
we also have an export mechanism in
cloud sql that allows you to export
your data in a portable format to google
cloud storage or gcs
this can be a multi-region bucket a
single region bucket or otherwise
when you use multi-region buckets it
ensures that in a regional outage your
data is automatically replicated and
stored in another region so you need
access to it
you can also store these exports in any
other object storage meaning
on-premises or in another cloud provider
it allows you a very
portable format of your data so that you
can take it where you want
in region ensure that you enable high
availability
high availability tells cloud sql the
high relativity configuration tells
about sql
to do automatic health checking of your
instance and to set up synchronous
replication between zones
so that in the event of a problem we
automatically fail over on your behalf
bringing your database back up even
after a major fault
this is necessary for the sla and
generally good availability guidance for
any production system
lastly as i mentioned to protect against
a region outage consider using our cross
region
replication or cross region replicas
again you'll have a near real time copy
asynchronous replication which means
you'll have data available to you in
another region
should your primary region have an
outage and you can make that data
accessible
very quickly to applications to get back
online
looking now at how to get automatic
transparency and trusted security
controls
will start with access transparency
access transparency gives you near
real-time logs
when a google cloud administrator
accesses your content
cloud audit logs already provide
visibility into the actions of your own
administrators
so for example your administrators might
be creating a cloud sql instance
taking a few backups via our api all
this is logged today
however this audit trail typically or
previously stopped
once your cloud provider support or
engineering team is engaged we
previously didn't log those transactions
now when you open a support ticket with
our support team
with via access transparency you'll see
their actions
in your audit log as well for our manual
and targeted accesses again either by
support or engineering to get your
database back online
you can take this further with access
approval so beyond just logging
and viewing the access you can use the
access approval
feature to increase your level of
control which
by requiring explicit approvals before
google support or engineering can access
your data or configurations on google
cloud
i recommend taking a look at both access
transparency and access approval to see
how they fit with your environment
next up let's look at encryption and
specifically customer managed encryption
keys
these keys are intended for
organizations that have sensitive
or regulated data that requires them to
manage their own encryption key
these keys are stored in a key
management system
that you manage we're using keys in
cloud sql that you manage
and we access them as part of our
operations
should you remove access from that team
then when cloud sql performs a major
operation next
it won't be able to get the key and
access to that system is shut down
again this feature allows you to use
cryptographic keys that you manage
to control your data at rest the data we
store in cloud sql
i mentioned earlier google cloud's
global vpcs
we've introduced in cloud sql support
for vpc
service controls these generally in gcp
allow you to define very fine grade
perimeter controls
across numerous google cloud services of
course including cloud sql
for cloud sql this pairs very well with
vpcs or private ip addresses
with the combination of private ip
addresses and vpc service controls
you're now able to make private your
cloud sql instances both from a data
path perspective
as well as a control path perspective
the private ip or vpc
allows you to protect the data path the
things that your clients and
applications are connected to
by using a private ip address on a vpc
that you control
vpc service controls for cloud sql
protect the administrative api
who can create cloud sql instances who
can take backups via the api or the ui
for example
you're now able to make our
administration api totally private as
well
ensuring that you can control where your
your teams can access cloud sql
instances not just on the data path
but also on the control path of the
admin api
let's round out with how to stay up to
date without the risk
as a reminder cloud sql has long offered
maintenance windows
which are one hour per week times when
used you define that google can perform
maintenance on your instance
in general cloud sql typically performs
maintenance once a quarter on your
instances to apply patches and keep
things up to date
we would adhere to your maintenance
window as you see in this diagram
one thing to note about maintenance
windows is that we offer
certain timings if in a given project
you have dev and test
database instances as well as some
production database instances
you might put the dev and test databases
on the earlier timing
and you might put the production
databases on the later timing
this ensures then that the dev test
instances on the earlier timing
get maintenance or receive maintenance
about a week in advance of your
production instances
that way it gives you a chance to test
the updates with your application before
they go into your production environment
we've recently added maintenance
notification and rescheduling
when you opt in we'll we'll email you a
week in advance of maintenance
letting you know that we're planning to
perform maintenance in your next
maintenance window
you get a few options as part of this
notification including the ability to
reschedule to a following
window one week later or the ability to
apply maintenance anytime you click the
apply now button
you can also set a specific time anytime
in the next two weeks
to apply maintenance if you're not happy
with your current maintenance windows
schedule
this gives you much more control as to
when maintenance is applied
especially on your production instances
and lets your teams know well in advance
that maintenance will be performed to
wrap
up hopefully these features help you
find a bit more flexibility in your
environment with things like
bigquery federation and committed use
discounts
helping you protect against the
unexpected be that user error with point
in time recovery or
a regional outage with cross-region
replication and disaster recovery
they'll allow you to get automatic
transparency and trusted security
controls
things like private ip and now the
addition of epc security controls for
example
as well as customer managed encryption
keys and we'll round it out with our new
maintenance notifications and
rescheduling functionality
as you can see cloud sql is continuing
to build this momentum with respect to
enterprise features
and you can expect to see more of this
in future offerings
for next steps i encourage you to take a
look at two other sessions
the first a data monetization story
where mckesson talks about their journey
to google cloud
and please take a look at the bare metal
solution which
will help you bring your enterprise
workloads to gcp
if you want to see cloud sql in action
take a look at our showcase demo which
is a whack-a-mole style
high availability demonstration i
mentioned high availability briefly
in this demonstration as i mentioned
whack-a-mole style
you'll get to see how many cloud
sequences can you make fail
and how many recover in the amount of
time you're given in the game take a
look
lastly get hands-on with cloud sql and
try it out with our quick labs quest
in the quest you'll be introduced to
cloud sql from beginner knowledge all
the way through advanced
touching on a lot of the features that
i've talked about today by the end i
think you'll feel very comfortable using
cloud sql
and you'll hopefully be taking advantage
of some of the enhancements that we've
brought out this year
thank you all for spending this time
with me and watching the session as i
mentioned i'll be available as part of
our google cloud next expert sessions if
you want to meet one-on-one and talk a
little more about cloud sql
thank you again